Follow Lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Malay language or
Bahasa Melayu as it's called in Malay.
People outside of Southeast Asia may not
be very familiar with Malaya,
but if we include all speakers of all
varieties of Malay,
it is one of the top 10 most widely
spoken languages in the world and when I
say widely,
I mean by a large number of people.
It has around 77 million native speakers
and around 173000002nd language speakers
for a total of about $250 million
speakers.
Of course,
different sources give different
numbers,
but something like that.
It's spoken in Malaysia where it has
around 18 point $5,
million native speakers out of a
population of around 32 million people.
Malaysia is an ethnically and
linguistically diverse place with large
communities of people speaking Chinese
and Indian languages as well as numerous
indigenous minority languages.
Everyone in Malaysia now learns Malaya
at school,
but some speakers of other languages
either aren't fluent in Malay or they
choose not to speak it very much after
they graduate from school.
Singapore is another ethnically diverse
place where Malays are a minority.
The Malay language is spoken by around
700,000
people.
There were 13 percent of the population.
It has also spoken by around 266,000
people or about 64 percent of the
population of Brunei.
What?
That.
It's not an idiot.
Oh yeah,
sorry.
In English we say Brunei.
Oh my God.
You slaughtered the word Bruny.
Okay.
I'm Bernay.
So like I was saying,
it's spoken by around 266,000
people or 64 percent of the population
of ru.
It has also spoken by around 1 million
people in southern Thailand adjacent to
peninsular,
Malaysia and Malaya spoken by around 11
point two,
3 million people in Indonesia.
But that's only part of the story.
There were also about $43,
million native speakers of Bahasa,
Indonesia and around 155 second language
speakers have Bahasa Indonesia.
So what's Bahasa Indonesia?
Well,
when speaking of the Malay language,
we need to distinguish between Malaya
dialects,
which vary from place to place and the
standardized forms of the language,
the first standardized form of the
languages,
but has some value which is used in
Malaysia,
Brunei,
and Singapore,
and functions as an umbrella language
for all of them.
Malaya dialects that are spoken there.
The second standardized form of the
language is Bahasa Indonesia.
It is used in Indonesia and functions as
a Lingua Franca between speakers of
different languages because there are
hundreds of languages in Indonesia.
I planned to focus specifically on
Indonesia and in a different video in
the future.
This is interesting in Malaysia,
the official name of Malaya is Bahasa
Malaysia,
meaning the language of Malaysia.
Instead of Bahasa Melayu,
which means the language of the Malays.
This name was chosen to show that the
language is a language for all Malaysian
citizens and not only for ethnic
malaise,
but some people want to change the name.
Back to Bahasa Melayu history.
Malaya is the most widely spoken
language in the Austronesian language
family.
The Austronesian can most likely be
traced back to a common ancestor,
Prodo Austronesian in what is now Taiwan
around 5,200
years ago,
various dialects of rose from protocol
Austronesian,
one of them being Polynesian,
which began splitting up into various
languages around 4,000
years ago as Austronesian people
expanded to the south from Taiwan.
The Malayan Polynesian sub branch
includes most of the Austronesian
languages outside of Taiwan,
a Prodo maleic language,
the ancestor of all Malaya dialects
probably originated on the island of
Borneo more than 2000 years ago before
it speakers migrated west to Sumatra and
the Malay peninsula old Malala,
the beginning of the common era.
And by that I mean after the year one ce
or one add same thing.
By the way,
was a time of great Indian influence in
the region and during this time old
Molay,
he merged.
It was highly influenced by Sanskrit and
written in Indian scripts like hot lava,
the oldest known inscriptions of old
Malaya,
the Kudu come Buki,
which were found in Sumatra and date
back to the seventh century ce,
the oldest old mill,
a manuscript that still exists today is
the 10th of June,
Tonna,
a legal text from the 14th century still
before Islam was widespread in the area,
classical Malay.
Islam soon became dominant in the area
and trade with the Muslim world,
increased,
resulting in a lot of Arabic and Persian
vocabulary entering the language and
resulting in the adoption of the script.
John [inaudible] is a version of the
Arabic script that was modified to suit
the Malay language during the Malacca
sultanates,
which was like a kingdom and its
successor,
the Johor Sultanate.
Malaya became widely used as a Lingua
Franca.
During this time,
Islamic literature greatly affected the
language with more Arabic and Persian
vocabulary entering Malaya,
and because Malacca was a busy
international port with people from
various countries,
Malaysia also absorbed vocabulary from
different languages,
Tamil and Chinese languages.
During this classical malaise period,
Malaya evolved into something relatively
similar to the Bahasa Melayu and Bahasa
Indonesia have today.
There were actually two forms of melee
that became widespread during this time
period.
First,
there was the formal classical malave,
which was the state language and the
language of courts and literature,
and there was bizarre Malaya or Malaysia
Passata,
a low language spoken by traders as a
Lingua Franca.
Throughout the archipelago bizarre
Malaya is thought to have been a pigeon
language featuring vocabulary from
Malaya,
but influenced by other languages such
as Chinese languages,
and there will also local Malaya
dialects that varied from place to
place.
Premodern molay.
In the 19th century,
European colonial powers were dominating
the region with the Dutch in Indonesia
and the British and Malaysia.
During this time period,
improvements to the printing press made
Malaya books and newspapers more widely
available to the common people so that
literary Malay or classical ballet was
no longer just the language of the
courts and the elite,
the literary Malaya of the Malacca and
the Johor Sultanates.
In other words,
classical ballet was recognized by the
British and the Dutch as the standard
form of the language and became the
language of education.
One notable change during the colonial
period was the adoption of the Roomi
writing system,
the use of Roman characters to write
molay instead of the script and English
loan words began to trickle into
Malaysia and the areas under British
control.
Modern Malaya,
the abundance of Malaya literature in
the 19th century sparked new enthusiasm
for the language and Malaya linguists
began their efforts to standardize and
modernize the language.
In 1936,
the Malays scholars,
the above,
published a series of books called Alita
Bahasa,
in which he updated the grammar of
classical ballet forming the basis of
Bahasa Melayu in Bahasa,
Indonesia.
In both Malaysia and Indonesia,
the standard form of Malaya became an
important part of their respect of
nationalist movements and their struggle
for independence.
When Indonesia declared independence in
1945,
Bahasa,
Indonesia became the national language
and when Malaysia became independent in
1957 Bas,
I'm ally.
You became the national language
dialects.
Bahasa Malaysia was the standard form of
Malaya used in Malaysia and Singapore
and then Bruni,
and it's the form of the language taught
in schools,
but there are numerous spoken dialects
of Malaya that very not only from
country to country but also from state
to state and from town to town with
differences in pronunciation and
vocabulary.
The Malays spoken at Saba and what tends
to be more similar to that spoken in
Brunei and Singapore,
but different from the dialects in west
Malaysia and some states in west
Malaysia are known for being quite
divergent.
For example,
the dialects of Colombia,
Colombian borders,
Thailand to the north where a similar
dialects spoken.
The differences that in on everyone
learns standard Malaya at school,
but in southern Thailand everyone learns
tie at school.
This makes cross dialect communication
harder for speakers of Malaysia and
Thailand,
but for speakers of other Malaya
dialects,
Standard Malaysia's a unifying force and
speaking a little more formally can help
people bridge communication gaps.
Standard Malaya is also the form of
Malaya learned by non malaise at school.
So Standard Malaya,
sometimes the language of inter ethnic
communication though some people choose
to speak English instead.
So what is my lay like?
Like most Austronesian languages,
Malaya is not a tonal language.
It has simple phonology and every
written character represents only one
sound.
In most cases.
It has a simple Svo sentence structure,
for example,
right?
Yeah.
Mark can tell you
meaning,
I eat vegetables,
I don't eat meat.
Now let's add a modal verb.
So yeah,
not my.
I don't want to eat meat.
So yeah,
that's not my conducting.
I told me no Zuzu.
I don't want to eat meat or drink milk.
Malaya grammar is simple.
First of all,
there's no grammatical gender.
There are also no noun cases.
There was also no plural form in
Malaysia.
If you want to make a plural explicit,
you reduplicate the word or repeat the
word.
Oh
means a person
all around,
all around
means people.
And speaking of autumn,
fun fact.
Ordnung means person in Malaysia who
done means forest in Oregon.
Cooten means forest person,
also known as Orangutang.
Cool.
If you want to modify a noun,
you add the modifying word after the
Noun,
the word for book book.
Cool.
Now let's add a demonstrative pronoun to
that book or with a possessive Pronoun
Crusader my book or Buku Buku saying my
books or with an adjective inexpensive
book.
In Malaysia,
there is no copy of the verb to be at
least in regular speech and there is no
definite or indefinite article,
so we could also mean the book is
expensive,
but to be more clear,
you might say prepositions in Malaya are
very straightforward and intuitive,
so yeah,
but I tell Daddy,
can I come from Canada?
Now I want to go to the night market at
dot.
There was a discount for students in
this sentence.
Other means there is one of the things
that makes learning my life fund is that
there are no verb conjugations.
The form of the verb stays exactly the
same regardless of whether it's in
present tense,
past tense or future tense.
So we have the verb meaning to eat in
present tense on in past tense,
in future tense.
Mock on the tents is determined by
specifying a time period like goodman he
will eat later or by using an adverb
before the verb game.
He will eat,
he already ate or her down.
He is currently eating what he's eating
now and there are some other adverts
like this,
but of course it's not quite that simple
because we have the verb game to eat,
but we also have the verb Dema came to
be eaten and they're going to be eating
accidentally and we have the verb moment
came to consume.
Then we have moma tend to feed something
to someone.
These are examples of one of my most
challenging features for learners.
It's system of building words from roots
and affixes up above.
We created some new verbs,
but we can also create other types of
words,
not Kenyan food.
Matt gain someone who eats,
so boomer.
Nagging means a mediator.
Malaya makes extensive use of this kind
of affixation.
Let's look at one more example of using
the root word [inaudible],
which means to teach.
I didn't teachings to learn to teach
again,
to be taught in transitive,
as in I'm being taught be a gay gain,
transitive as in the lesson is being
taught to study,
to be studied by student,
but now gay teacher,
Bombilla,
Gauteng,
learning bird to be educated.
All of these affixes might seem
overwhelming at first,
but they're fairly systematic and once
you get used to the function of all of
the different affixes,
then it helps you to understand words
that you've never heard before and it
helps you to guess how to say words that
you don't know yet.
Standard Malaya is a very user friendly
language for learners,
especially if you're used to learning
more complex languages.
The biggest challenge that you'll likely
face as the difference between the
formal language and the casual language
and the dialectal variation that you'll
especially different pronunciation,
but by learning the standard polite form
of malaria,
you form a good basis for communication
and you can learn the more colloquial
style of communication as you go.
Stay tuned for a future episode in which
I cover Bahasa,
Indonesia,
and they'll focus in on that form of
Malays specifically.
Be sure to subscribe to Lang,
focus and follow us,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and I'd like to say thank you to all of
my patrion supporters,
especially the ones on the screen right
now for their generous support every
month.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.
By the way means language.